สวัสดีค่ะครูเรียมสวัสดีค่ะครูหญิงสวัสดี
ค่ะนักเรียนทุกคนสวัสดีค่ะนักเรียนครู
เรียมวันนี้วันอะไรคะวันนี้วันอังคารค่ะ
อุ๊ยค่ะเดี๋ยเขียนเป็นภาษาไทยดีกว่าวัน
อังคาร
ค่ะวันที่เท่าไหร่คะวันที่
16 เดือนอะไรคะเดือน
สิงหาคมสิงหาคมเป็นเดือนที่ 8 เนาะใช่ค่ะ
ปีพ.ศอะไรคะปี
พ.ศ
2565 ค่ะปีค.ศอะไรคะปี
ค.ศ
222 ค่ะค่ะแล้วตอนนี้เวลากี่โมงคะครู
เรียมตอนนี้ 9
น 6 นค่ะโอ 96 นตอนเช้า่ใช่ใช่ตอนเช้าครู
เรียมกินข้าวหรือยังคะตื่นนอนแล้วยังไม่
กินเลย
ค่ะแล้วผู้หญิงล่ะคะกินข้าวหรือ
ยังเยูหญิงไอเหรอคะครูหญิงยังครูหญิงกิน
แล้วอันนี้ครูหญิงตอนกลางคืนครูหญิงก็จะ
ไม่กินกับครูเรียมไปด้วยนะของครูหญิง
เนี่ยตอนนี้มัน
ประมาณ 22:00 นแล้วค่ะ 22:00 นแล้ว 22 น
ก็กินได้กินข้าวแล้ว่อิกแล้วอีแล้วอีแล้ว
กินเยอะวันนี้กินเยอะเอออ๋อใช่แต่ว่าครู
เรียมก็ยังไม่ได้กินข้าวใช่มั้ยคะเนี่ย
คือครูหญิงจะบอกว่าครูหญิงเนี่ยก็ไปกิน
อาหารที่แบบมันต้องใช้มืออ่ะมือในการจับ
แล้วแบบมันก็มีกลิ่นของอาหารอยู่อ่ะขนาด
เราล้างล้างมือแล้วนะมันก็ยังมีกลิ่นน่ะ
แล้วเราก็แบบเราเป็นผู้หญิงใช่มั้ยคะผู้
หญิงเนี่ยก็ชอบเอามือแบบจับผมไงผู้หญิง
ส่วนใหญ่จะชอบจับผมตัวเองมยชอบจับผมคิด
ว่าผมครูหญิงเนี่ยน่าจะมีกลิ่นอาหารแล้ว
ล่ะ
อืหรือว่าบางทีเราไปกินแบบอะไรนะหมูกระทะ
แบบที่ต้องปิ้งย่างแล้วมันจะมีควันขึ้นมา
ผมก็จะแบบมีกลิ่นใชคค่ะอือืเอ้าแล้วผู้
หญิงก็ไปสระผม
ไงใช่ๆคือครูหญิงอ่ะปกติผู้หญิงก็จะสระผม
เองใช่มยนอกจากว่าวันไหนที่เรารู้สึกแบบ
โอ๊ยขี้เกียจจริงๆอ่ะเออขี้เกียจแบบว่า
คือถ้าเราสะผมเองเราก็
ต้องเ่าผมเป่าผมใช่ค่ะไผมหรือว่าเป่าผม
อย่างเงี้ยแบบขี้เกียจดับเบิ้ลน่ะใช่คือ
นอกษจะต้องสระผม
แล้วยังจะต้องไดผมอีกแบบโอขี้เกียจมากๆ
ผู้หญิงรู้มั้ยเรียมเคยทำยังไงถ้าแบบมัน
ดึกๆนะดึกๆแล้วไปร้านเสริมสวยไม่ได้เรียม
ก็จะสระผมแล้วเรียมก็นอนบนเตียงใช่มยแล้ว
ก็เอาผมลงมาแล้วก็เอาพัดลม
เป่าแล้วก็นอนแบบเนี้ยตื่นขึ้นมาปวดคอปวด
คอ้าูหญิงกำลังจะบอกเลยว่าอุ๊ยไอเดียดี
มากเลยค่ะปวดคอค่ะครูหญิงไม่ไหวจริงๆคิด
ว่าไปที่ร้านเสริมสวยดี
กว่าใช่ค่ะเพราะว่าแบบว่าเค้าก็เราก็นอน
สบายๆมีคนสะผมให้แล้วร้านเสริมสวยของผู้
หญิงเนี่ยคือไม่ได้สะอย่างเดียวไงนวดด้วย
ใช่มยใช่แล้วเรียมก็ชอบเวลาที่เา้า
เกา
อืเกาแบบอืบางคนก็แบบเกาเจ็บมากนะเออใช่ๆ
ๆแต่บางคนก็
ชอบใช่ค่ะครูหญิงเคยไปแบบร้านทำผมคือ
เมื่อก่อนน่ะข้างหน้ามหาวิทยาลัยอ่ะค่ะ
โอ๊ยขอโทษค่ะคัน
คอร้านข้างหน้ามหาวิทยาลัยอ่ะมันก็จะมี
แบบร้านทำผมเยอะๆอืเยอะมากๆขอโทษค่ะครู
เรียมขอดื่มน้ำก่อนได้ค่ะครุหญิงดื่มน้ำ
ก่อนชนชนหน่อยมั้ยคะผู้
หญิง
โอเค
สนนะคะคือนักเรียนคือุหญิงอ่ะเจ็บคอนะคะ
เจ็บคออือืใช่แต่ว่าตรวจแล้วนะคือบอกทุก
คลิปเลยอ่ะว่าตรวจแล้วนะแต่ไม่เป็นอะไร
ใช่อ่ะกลับมาเรื่องของเรานะคะก็คือจะบอก
ว่าเมื่อก่อนข้างหน้ามหาวิทยาลัยอ่ะค่ะ
เขาก็จะมีแบบร้านทำผมเยอะมาก
ๆร้านเสริมสวยนี่แหละเออหรือว่าร้านก็ได้
เรียกร้านเสริมสวยร้านทำผมร้านตัดผมใช่มม
คะอืก็คล้ายๆกันแต่ถ้าเป็นร้านตัดผมของ
ผู้ชายเนี่ยเอาไม่เรียกร้านเสริมสวยนะ
เรียกร้านตัดผมไปเลยแต่ถ้าของผู้หญิงอ่ะ
เรียกได้หลายอย่างเนาะเออใช่ๆคือถ้าแบบ
พูดคำว่าร้านเสริมสวยมันก็จะดูแบบออกไป
แนวแบบต่างจังหวัดบ้านเราหน่อยมยบ้านเรา
ใช่บ้านูหญิงเขาคก็เรียกว่าร้านเสริมสวย
ไงกับชลบุรีเค้าก็เรียกว่าร้านเสริมสวย
เพราะว่าเวลาเด็ก็อ่ะเราจะไปตัดผมก็คือไป
ตัดผมสั้นไม่มีแฟชั่นน่ะมีทรงผมอะไรไม่
ได้เพราะว่าโรงเรียนไม่ให้ใช่อืมันก็จะมี
แบบร้านตัดผมแล้วก็ร้านเสริมสวยที่แบบคือ
ร้านเสริมสวยมันไม่ได้แค่ทำผมอย่างเดียว
ไงคะทาเล็บใช่มั้เ้าทำเล็บด้วยทำเล็บมือ
เล็บเท้าอืประมาณนี้นะูหญิงแบบสระผมตัด
ผมบางบางร้านก็มีแต่งหน้าให้ด้วยเออใช่
ค่ะหรือว่าทำผมให้เราอ่ะแต่ว่าสมมุติว่า
วันนี้เราจะไปงานนะอยากได้ทรงผมแบบกราว
สูงๆอย่างเงี้ยเอ่อเขาก็จะทำผมให้เราทำไม
เราถึงเรียกว่าร้านเสริมสวนสวยไงคะเพราะ
ว่าทำให้เราสวยใช่แต่ว่าเชยไปที่แบบแถว
หน้ามหาวิทยาลัยอ่ะค่ะแล้วเราก็จะไปคือคุ
หญิงก็ไปตัดผมนี่แหละแต่ว่าพอตก่อนที่เรา
จะไปตัดผมเนี่ยเขาก็จะสับผมให้เราก่อน
แล้วช่างอ่ะค่ะเขาก็จะบอกเลยว่าถ้าเจ็บ
บอกนะหรือช่างเขาจะเกาใช่มยคะแล้วมัน
เหมือนครูเรียมอ่ะผู้หญิงไม่รู้ว่าเค้าเ
ตัดเล็บอ่ะแล้วตะไบเล็บเป็นแบบแหลมๆหรือ
เปล่าอ่ะมันเจ็บมากอ่ะเจ็บคือปกติครูอิง
อดทนได้ไม่เป็นไรเพราะว่าแบบเจ็บนิดหน่อย
แต่มันไม่ได้ใช้เวลาในการสะนานแต่มันมี
อยู่ครั้งนึงที่แบบว่ามันไม่ไหวจริงๆแล้ว
แบบร้านทำผมเขาจะชอบสระให้เราอย่างน้อย 2
ครั้งใช่ใช่มั้ยแล้วก็นวดอีก 1 ครั้งอ่ะ
อันนี้เพิ่งสะครั้งแรกแล้วแบบคิดว่าเลือด
ออกหัวหรือเปล่า้าก็เลยแบบได้บอกเค้ามั้ย
คะบอกค่ะทนไม่ไหวจริงๆครูเรียมครูหญิงคิด
ว่าถ้าครูหญิงไม่บอกเนี่ยเค้าเอายาสระผม
ใส่ครั้งที่ 2 อ่ะคุหญิงน่าจะแบบน่าจะแสบ
ผมมากๆอ่ะเออแสบหัวมากๆก็เลยแบบบอกเค้านะ
คะว่า
โอเคเจ็บค่ะพี่คะเจ็บเค้าก็เลยแบบอโอเค
เค้าก็จะแบบเบทำให้เบาๆเบาๆเออเพราะว่า
จริงๆหลายๆคนชอบนะคะแบบว่าเวลาไปร้านทำผม
หรือว่าร้านตัดผมอ่ะแล้วแบบสะผมแล้วเเกา
ให้เราอ่ะมีแต่คนชอบนะแต่แต่ผู้หญิงไม่
ค่อยชอบอ่ะเรียมนี่แหละชอบเรียมก็บอกเอา
เลยค่ะเต็มที่เลยเก็
แบบเจ็บ่าเจ็บสบายเลยชอบเหมือนกันอดทนไง
อดทนก็เออแต่ก็โอเคชอบทนได้ใช่ค่ะแล้วก็
นวดอ่ะครูเรียมชอบมยเวลาที่เขานวดให้เรา
อ่ะนวดตรงตรงนี้เราเรียกว่าไ้ทอยใช่มั้ย
ไ้ทอยนวดตรงไ้ทอยกับก็จะนวดไ้ทอยแล้วก็
นวดหัวให้เราไม่ใช่เกานะเไม่ได้เกานะเนวด
ครูเรียมชอบมยเวลาเค้าแบบนวดหัวให้เรียม
ชอบชอบมากค่ะถ้าร้านไหนนวดหัวนวดแบบท้าย
ทอยนวดดีๆนะเรมก็จะชอบร้านนี้ก็จะเข้า
ร้านนี้เข้าร้านนี้แบบเนี้ยร้านไหนนวดดี
อ่ะเรียมก็จะชอบ
เข้าผู้หญิงชอบมั้ยผู้หญิงเนี่ยนวดหัวตรง
เนี้ยโอเคแต่นวดท้ายทอยอ่ะไม่ชอบเพราะว่า
มันเคยมีครั้งนึงที่เขาเหมือนไม่รู้ว่า
เขาอาจจะนวดแรงไปหรือเปล่าแล้วแบบเราไม่
เคยนวดไงอืแล้วมันมันเหมือนเมาๆอ่ะเค้า
เรียกอะไรมันเหมือนมึนๆอ่ะรู้สึกมึนเออ
มันเหมือนมึนๆรู้สึกแบบใช่เราก็เลยแบบว่า
พี่คะไม่ไม่เอาไม่ต้องนวดเพราะว่าไ้ทอย
มันก็แบบไม่รู้ว่าเา้านวดเป็นหรือเปล่าไง
ก็เลยไม่ค่อยชอบถ้าเขานวดให้เราอื
อ๋อหรอของเรียมจะเป็นแบบชอบแบบปึกๆๆๆๆๆ
อะไรก็ูเรียมชอบอะไรรุนแรงนะคะนักเรียน
นวดๆแล้วก็แบบจับปัๆๆอย่างเงี้ยเจะมี
อย่างงี้บอกเดี๋ยว
ใชเดี๋ยวอันนี้ครูเรียมไปร้านเสริมสวย
หรือว่าไปร้านนวดคะไปร้านเสริมสวยที่ชอบ
ร้านที่แบบมีนวดนวดเยอะๆนวดหัวนวดแบบคอ
แล้วก็แบบอะไรแบบเนี้ยอ๋อก็คือถ้าร้านไหน
มีแบบนี้เนี่ยครูเรียมก็คือจะไปร้านนี้
ทุกครั้งถ้าเลือกได้ใช่
ใช่ถ้าร้านนี้ปิดก็จะไปลองร้านใหม่ว่า
ร้านนี้นวดดีหรือเปล่าถ้านวดดีก็อไปร้าน
นี้ด้วยเออโอเคอย่างน้อยก็มี 2 ช้อยส์ใช่
มั้ยคะใช่ๆค่ะอือนั่นแหละคหญิงอ่ะไปทำ
อะไร
อีกเพราะว่าเมื่อก่อนน่ะครูหญิงเป็นคนชอบ
ชอบตัดผมตัดแบบเกือบทุกเดือนน่ะค่ะคือมัน
คือสมัยก่อนน่ะหน้ามหาวิทยาลัยอ่ะมันมี
ร้านตัดผมเยอะมากอ่ะค่ะกูเรียนบางทีมัน
แบบ 8  80 บาท 100 บาทอ่ะก็คือสระด้วยนะ
สระแล้วก็ซอยคือไม่ได้ตัดอย่างงี้อย่าง
เดียวแบบซอยผมแล้วก็ไดไดแบบเป่าผมอย่าง
เงี้ยเราก็เลยแบบเออเรียนเสร็จแล้วรู้สึก
ผมยาวและเบื่อไปตัดผมดี
กว่าหรอผู้หญิง 1 เดือนตัดผม 1 ครั้งเออ
บางทีแบบถ้าอยากตัดก็ตัดอย่างเงี้ยค่ะเรา
รู้สึกว่าแบบเออผมยาวแล้วอ่ะก็ไปตัดก็ตัด
บ่อยแบบตัดบ่อยมากๆแต่ไม่ได้ตัดออกเยอะนะ
ครูเรียมก็คือไม่รู้ว่าจ่ายตังค์ตัดผม
ทำไมอืเพราะว่าอย่างสมมุติเราตัดผมเสร็จ
แล้วใช่มแล้วเราปล่อยผมมันก็โอเคแต่ครู
หญิงตัดเสร็จแล้วก็มัดผมก็ไม่มีใครรู้
หรอกค่ะว่าตัดผมใช่แต่แค่มีความรู้สึกว่า
อยากตัดผมอ่ะก็ไปตัดอย่างเงี้ยแล้วแบบแถว
ๆมหาวิทยาลัยเนี่ยมันราคาถูกมากๆก็เลยไป
ตัดแล้วทีเนี้ยพอเราตัดเสร็จใช่มั้ยคะทุก
อย่างเสร็จแล้วเนี่ยช่างเนี่ยเขาก็จะไดผม
ให้เราสมัยนั้นเนี่ยเขาคก็จะฮิตแบบผมตรง
ใช่เขาไม่ได้นิยมผมหยิกๆเหมือนตอนนี้ใช่
ตงมากเลยนะตรงแบบ
ใช่ตรงแบบ
โหแล้วทีเนี้ยเวลาที่เขาไดอ่ะค่ะมันก็จะ
มีไดใช่มยไดอ่ะเดี๋ยวิงเปิดรูปให้ดูก็ได้
ค่ะแบบ
พอืใช่ๆๆอย่างเงี้ยช่างเค้าก็จะไดผมให้
เราซึ่งช่างประเทศไทยหน่อนะ
คะนี่นะ
อ่านี่นะคะเห็นมั้ยเา้าก็จะไดฟผมใช่มย
เนี่ยมีไดนะคะแล้วเก็จะไดผมให้เราคือการ
ไดผมในประเทศไทยเนี่ยก็ต้องคอแข็งแรง
เหมือนกันนะ
ใช่เพราะว่าช่างดึงทีนึง
แบบแบบดึงทีแบบว่าโอ้ถ้าเรานั่งเพลินๆแบบ
ยิ่งถ้าเป็นแบบตอนเนี้ยมีอินเทอร์เน็ต
แล้วนั่งเล่นโทรศัพท์เพลินๆนี่หงายหลัง
ได้เลยนะเพราะช่างดึงทีนึงแบบหูดึงแบบ
เนี้ยดึงแบบใช่ๆเห็นมั้ครูเรียมก็พูด
เหมือนกันน่ะก็แปลว่าผู้หญิงไม่ได้โม้นะ
คะนักเรียนใช่สระผมเรียมรู้สึกสบายนะแต่
แต่บางร้านเนี่ยเวลาที่ไดดผมอ่ะเป่าผม
เนี่ยปวดคอเพราะเราต้องแบบ
อใช่คือเราต้องยื้อกับเา้าอ่ะค่ะึงใช่ใช่
ๆคือเขาอ่ะดึงไปแต่เราต้องเอาคอเราแบบไม่
ไม่ไปช่างก็ดึงตไม่ไปไม่ไปเหมือนสู้กัน
น่ะนักเรียนแบบ
โอ้โหนอกจากดึงแรงแล้วเนี่ยยังเป่าอ่ะคือ
คุหญิงเคยไปมี 1 ครั้งอ่ะค่ะครูเรียมร
ร้านเดิมนี่แหละแต่ว่าร้านเนี้ยเขาจะมี
ช่างหลายคนแล้วครูหญิงเนี่ยเป็นคนที่ไม่
แบบเป็นคนที่เปลี่ยนเปลี่ยนช่างตัดผมทุก
ครั้งอเพราะว่าอาจจะไม่มีคนที่เราชอบไม่
มีคนที่ถูกใจไงเออเราก็เปลี่ยนทุกครั้ง
แล้วก็แบบเคยมี 1 ครั้งอ่ะค่ะที่เขาไดอ่ะ
ไดจนแบบเราได้กลิ่นแบบกลิ่นเอ๊ี่ผมเราสุก
แล้วหรือเปล่าอ่ะกลิ่นผมมันไม่้อ่ะคือได
เป่าผมอ่ะมันร้อนมากๆใช่มั้ยคะพอมันร้อน
แล้วมันถูกับผมเราอยู่อย่างเงี้ยนานๆน่ะ
แล้วแบบ
อื้อหือผมไหม้เลยอ่ะค่ะได้กลิ่นเลยอ่ะแบบ
ตายแล้วแล้วครูหญิงบอกอะไรเค้ามั้ยเค้าก็
รู้ค่ะครูเรียมก็ครูหญิงอ่ะไม่บอกหรอก
เป็นคนไม่พูดไงเป็นคนอดทนส่วนใหญ่จะเป็น
คนอดทนรู้สึกโอเคไม่เป็นไรเหมือนเหมือแบบ
ไอ้ที่เกาหัวบอกใช่ไหมมแต่เวลาที่ช่างได
ผมอ่ะแล้วเป่าคือนอกจากไอ้การเป่าผมเรา
อ่ะค่ะแล้วผมเราไหม้เนี่ยมันมี
เปอร์เซ็นต์น้อยไม่ค่อยมีหรอกใช่ๆแต่เป่า
หูหูของเราเนี่ยจนหูของเราร้อนแบบร้อนมาก
ๆเนี่ย
99% สมัยก่อนนะใชแต่ว่าตอนนี้ไม่ค่อยมี
นะตอนนี้ก็ช่างช่างทำผมเก่งๆเยอะใช่แล้ว
ผู้หญิงก็คิดว่าอาจจะคุณภาพของไดเนี่ยมัน
ดีขึ้นด้วยมยไดเนี่ยไดเป่าผมเนี่ยมันอาจ
จะดีขึ้นมันมีแบบความร้อนที่แบบเออโอเค
ใช่ค่ะคือแบบช่างจะใดจนแบบหูหูเราร้อนมาก
ๆอ่ะแตู่้หญิงก็ไม่บอกนะหญิงว่าไม่เป็นไร
ไม่เป็นไรเดี๋ยวมันก็เสร็จแล้วเดี๋ยวมัน
ก็เสร็จแล้วใช่เดี๋ยวมันก็เหมือนกันแล้ว
บางทีล่ะเรารู้สึกร้อนหูแล้วก็หนังศีรษะ
เนี่ยแล้วก็จืดแล้วก็ยร้อนร้อนแต่ไม่พูด
นะคงจะแบบนิดเดียวแหละอีกสักพักนึงก็จืด
โอร้อนๆร้อนแบบช่างเไม่รู้จริงๆหรอว่าคน
ที่เขาไดผมให้อ่ะเราร้อนคือขนาดครูเรียม
ก็ยังร้อนครูเรียมกับครูหญิงก็คงไม่ได้ได
ผมที่เดียวกันใช่แต่เรายังเจอเหมือนๆกัน
ก็คือแบบเาเป่าผมร้อนมากๆมากคือตอนที่ครู
หญิงเ่อไดจนผมไหม้อ่ะค่ะเลยแบบรู้สึกไม่
โอเคอ่ะกลับบ้านมาก็เลยสะผมเพราะว่ามันมี
กลิ่นแบบแรงมากๆอ่ะครูเรียมพอเราสะผม
เสร็จแล้วอ่ะเราจับปลายผมของเราที่มัน
ไหม้อ่ะเราแค่เราจับอ่ะเราก็รู้เลยว่าผม
เราไม่โอเคอเหมือนผมของเราแล้วก็มีไฟอ่ะ
แล้วก็จุดไฟอย่างเงี้ยเลยแบบคุหญิงแบบโอ้
คุหยิงเข้าร้านนั้นอีกมั้ย
เอ่อก็เข้านะครูเรียมเข้าแต่ว่าเปลี่ยนคน
ใช่มั้ยส่วนใหญ่มันไม่ได้เจอคนเดิมค่ะครู
เรียมเพราะว่าเามีช่างตัดผมแบบเยอะมากๆอื
เยอะแบบเยอะใช่อืแล้วเวลาคูอ๋อเวลาที่ครู
หญิงตัดผมครูหญิงเคยเจอมยที่แบบเอารูปให้
ช่างดูแล้วแบบอยากได้ทรงนี้ค่ะอยากได้แบบ
อย่างเงี้ย
ค่ะเคยมยโอ้ใช่ค่ะเพราะว่าเวลาเราผู้หญิง
เราใช่มยเราจะไปตัดผมเนี่ยเราจะเซฟรูปมา
จาก Google ก่อนว่าเราจะเอาผมทรงไหนแล้ว
เราก็เซฟไปในโทรศัพท์แล้วเราก็ไปให้ช่าง
ดูคุหญิงไม่เคยได้ทรงที่อยากได้เลย
อ้าวทำไมคะคือช่างเขาจะบอกเลยว่าอ่ะอย่าง
แรกเลยบางทรงเนี่ยเราเอาไปให้ช่างดูคือ
คุณหญิงจะเป็นคนชอบผมสั้นอืมเป็นคนแบบ
เวลาไปตัดก็คือส่วนใหญ่จะตัดผมสั้นน่ะค่ะ
อ่าแล้วช่างก็จะบอกว่าอ๋อทรงนี้เนี่ยมัน
ต้องเซตทุกวันนะตื่นนอนมาเนี่ยต้องเซตผม
แล้วครูหญิงเนี่ยเป็นคนผมผมหยิกใช่มผม
อยากโศกแบบเนี้ยเห็นมั้ยเนี่ยอยากโศกเออ
เนผมมันหยิกอย่างเงี้ยค่ะนักเรียนหยิกแบบ
นิดหน่อยเรียกว่าผมอยาก
โศกใช่ช่างก็บอกว่ามันตัดไม่สวยช่างก็ไม่
ตัดให้หรือที่คุหญิงเจอบ่อยมากก็คือผม
หน้าม้าใช่มยผมผมหน้าม้าตรงเนี้ยมีผมผมๆ
คือครูหญิงกับครูเรียมเนี่ยไม่มีผมหน้า
ม้านะคะไม่มีไม่มีเรา 2 คนเนี่ยไม่ได้ตัด
ผมหน้าม้าอ่าถ้าผมนำมาก็คือเขาจะมีผมอยู่
ที่นี่ใช่มมีผมลงมาอใช่ๆซึ่ง
ครูหญิงอ่ะอยากตัดผมหน้าม้ามากๆแต่ไม่เคย
มีช่างคนไหนตัดให้เลยนะครูเรียมทำไม
คะคือเขาคจะบอก 2 อย่างค่ะ 1 หน้ากลมอ
หน้ากลมเนี่ยตัดหน้าม้าไม่สวยอืแล้วก็ 2
ผู้หญิงเนี่ยเป็นคนหน้าผากหน้าผากแคบคือ
หน้าผากเล็กอ่ะค่ะหน้าผากมันเล็กตัดผม
หน้าม้าไม่ได้พี่หิก็เลยแบบอ๋อทำไมอ่ะคือ
คุณหญิงก็เคยบอกช่างนะว่าไม่เป็นไรค่ะ
โอเคอคือคุหญิงจำได้ว่าเคยมีช่าง 1  1
ร้านน่ะซึ่งเรารู้สึกว่าเราเราตั้งใจไป
ร้านนี้เพราะว่าร้านเนี้ยแพงอ่าแพงมากเรา
ก็เลยรู้สึกว่าเคคงตัดให้เราแหละเพราะว่า
เขาเป็นช่างแพงใช่มยแล้วเเป็นร้านที่พูด
ไม่ดีมามากค่ะครูเรียมเค้าบอกเลยว่าคือ
พูดประมาณว่าแบบหน้าแบบเนี้ยคือเค้าพูด
คือครูหญิงจำไม่ได้ 100% น่ะแต่เขาไม่ได้
พูดแบบว่าไม่เอานะแบบเราเราหน้าผ่าแคบอ่ะ
ตัดหน้าม้ามันไม่สวยอ่ะบางร้านเจะพูดแบบ
นี้ใช่มั้ยคะแต่คนเนี้ยเขาจะพูดประมาณแบบ
มันไม่สวยหรอกตัดไปมันไม่โอเคหน้าตาแบบ
นี้จะมาตัดหน้าม้าได้ยังไงคือพูดไม่ดีอ่ะ
ครูเหลี่มอูยหญิงก็เลยแบบไม่ตัดได้คือคง
คิดว่าตอนเไม่รู้ร้านนี้ยังมีอยู่หรือ
เปล่านะคะแต่ว่าเป็นร้านที่จำได้ว่าพูด
ไม่ดีมากๆแต่ทุกร้านค่ะไม่เคยตัดผมหน้า
ม้าให้ครูหญิงเลยครูหญิงไม่ลองตัดเองใช่ๆ
คุณหญิงเคยตัดเองใช่ค่ะสวยหรือไม่ก็ให้
เพื่อนเมื่อก่อนให้เพื่อนที่ทำงานตัดให้
มันก็โอเคนะคือครูเรียมบางร้านน่ะเจะตัด
ให้เราแต่เจะตัดให้เราแบบนี้ใช่มั้ยเป็น
หน้าม้าแบบนี้โค้งอ่าหน้าม้าโค้งแต่บาง
ร้านเ้าบอกว่าไม่ตัดไม่ตัดให้เลย
อ๋อไม่เลยคือคือเราเอาเอารูปเนี้ยให้เค้า
ดูแต่เขาตัดออกมาบอกผู้หญิงบอกเะเค้าก็
บอกว่าทรงนั้นน่ะไม่ได้เหรอไม่เข้ากับ
หน้าอันนี้แหละสวยแล้วอย่างแบบอหน้าของ
ฉันนะใช่ถ้าฉันชอบฉันโอเคเนี่ยก็โอเคไง
เออใช่ค่ะุหญิงก็เลยแบบเออร้านทำผมที่ไทย
ส่วนใหญ่เป็นอย่างนี้จริงๆนะใช่เค้าถ้าคน
ที่น้ากลมแบบครูหญิงอย่างเงี้ยส่วนใหญ่
เลยอ่ะอยากมีหน้าม้าต้องตัดเองใช่ช่า่ง
ไม่ค่อยตัดให้ช่า่งไม่ค่อยตัดให้ผู้หญิง
แต่เรียมก็ค่อยถึงเรียมจะหน้าแหลมนะเรียม
ให้ชช่างตัดหน้าม้าให้เมื่อตอนประมาณ 10
ปีที่แล้ว 10 กว่าปีที่แล้วเขาชอบหน้าม้า
กันใช่มยให้ช่างตัดให้เรียมก็บอกช่างคะ
มันไม่ตรงมันไม่ตรงช่างก็ตัด
เออยังไม่ตรงค่ะช่างยังไม่ตรงช่างก็ตัด
ขึ้นไปอีกสรุปอยู่หน้ามาเรียมอยู่ตรง
เนี้ยหน้ามาเรียมอยู่ตรงนี้
ิงแล้วแบบออพอคิดว่าตัดเองดีกว่าูเรียก็
เลยบอกว่าถ้ายังพูดไม่อยู่ที่สงสัยจะอยู่
ที่นี่แล้วนะหน้าม้าเหน้าม้าเต่อเลยอ่ะ
ตรงเคือหน้าม้าเตอหนแฟชั่นมาตั้งแต่ 10
ปีที่แล้วเลยนะคะหน้าม้าเตอใช่ๆ
โอเคเนาะเนี่ยแหละค่ะก็เป็นเรื่องเกี่ยว
กับร้านเสริมสวยหรือว่าร้านทำผมเนาะที่
เรา 2 คนเนี่ยเอามาเล่าให้นักเรียนฟังนะ
คะใช่ค่ะวันนี้เวลาหมดแล้วค่ะครูหญิงได้
ค่ะเดี๋ยวเรามาเจอกันใหม่ในวดีโอหน้านะคะ
ใช่ค่ะสำหรับวันนี้ต้องลาไปก่อนสวัสดีค่ะ
สวัสดี
ค่ะ